so i've been looking over the leaks and
rumors for the m1x mac mini and trying
to put all the puzzle pieces together
and i think that i finally nailed it
thanks to both some brand new and old
leaks that make total sense leading me
to believe that apple will be revealing
the new redesigned m1x mac mini at their
october event here in just a couple of
months but before i explain my reasoning
and show you the evidence for why this
makes so much sense i want to analyze
some of the leaks concerning the design
the chip the ports and the pricing back
in may john prosser revealed renders of
the upcoming redesigned mac mini created
by ian zelbo using a combination of
photos schematics and other details and
you can see right here that it's a much
slimmer version of the current mac mini
as you can see in this side by side
photo scaled to match the size of the
ports now this really makes sense
because the much shorter or thinner
design matches what apple did with the
24 inch imac taking advantage of their
efficient and cool apple silicon chips
but the interesting part about these
renders is that leeks apple pro actually
revealed the legitimate apple schematics
that john was using basically confirming
the design and what's great about this
is that the schematics show off the new
magnetic power connector that apple is
using for the 24 inch imac which makes
perfect sense for apple to reuse in the
mac mini but what makes this really
crazy is that back on may 10th john
prosser showed off the bottom of the
macbook air with a new design for the
grippy bottom stands and this perfectly
matches the bottom of the 24-inch imac
which was only released weeks after
john's video and these are actually the
same bottom pads that we see on john's
m1x mac mini renders as well as leaks
apple pro schematics so i'm fairly
certain that they're totally legit and
spot on now the next detail i want to
get into is the apparent plexiglass top
on the m1x mac mini that john showed off
in his video well first of all the
league schematics basically confirmed
this detail as well but going even
further if we go back to 2005 and look
at the original mac mini it actually
featured a flat plastic top with an
apple logo which many people have
forgotten about so apple could truly be
going back to their roots with the m1x
mac mini like they did with the imac
redesign as well as the rumored macbook
air with white bezels and color options
and of course the m1x macbook pro with
the return of a bunch of ports and the
removal of the touch bar so in reality
the new plexiglas top on the mac mini
truly makes sense based on what they did
in the past so all of those details are
basically leading me to believe that the
leaks and renders from john prosser are
completely legit and that this mac mini
should be coming soon now moving on to
the chip that's going to be going into
the new mac mini i 100 guarantee that it
will be coming with the m1x chip as the
sole option with 10 cores for the cpu
either 16 or 32 cores for the gpu and
potentially up to 64 gigabytes of ram
based on leaks from mark german who says
that's exactly what's going to be going
into the mac mini now on top of all of
that the reliable analyst dylan dkt on
twitter also believes that it's getting
the same exact m1x chip that's going
into the macbook pros and just going off
of the fact that the lower end mac mini
got the same exact m1 chip as the lower
end macbook pro it makes perfect sense
for the same thing to happen with the
higher end mac mini getting the same m1x
chip that the macbook pros are going to
be getting and this basically has to
happen based on apple's two-year apple
silicon transition since the current mac
mini still has a higher end intel based
model just like the high-end 13-inch and
16-inch macbook pros still have an intel
model that apple is selling now before i
get into the pricing which is the most
interesting part let me now explain why
i'm so confident in an october reveal
date for the new mac mini first off mark
german recently said that he expects the
redesign mac mini to launch shortly
after the m1x macbook pros but the thing
is that the word launch does not mean
reveal and the important thing to
realize is that the mac mini hasn't
truly been redesigned since 2010 so the
new mac mini obviously deserves to be
revealed at an apple event on top of
that dillon dkt also agrees that the mac
midi will be revealed alongside the new
macbook pros and so does leaks apple pro
who recently mentioned that they'll be
coming at the same time so if you
combine all of those pieces of info i
believe there's a good chance that both
the mac mini and the new macbook pros
will be revealed at the same october
event but they'll end up shipping at
different times so maybe the mac mini
will truly launch a month after the
event or something like that now going
even deeper if you really think about it
last year's november event was focused
on apple silicon and the new m1 chip
first and foremost before apple showed
off which products would be getting that
chance so i expect the october event to
do basically the same thing with apple
showing off the m1x chip and making a
huge deal about how powerful it is
before showing off the very first
redesigned products that will be getting
that chat now moving on the last big
question i still haven't answered is why
i'm so confident that the event will
happen in october instead of november so
let's get right into that first off the
reason we had the m1 mac event in
november last year was because the
iphone 12 ended up getting delayed by
one month so apple had to make the
october event that was usually always
focused on macs and ipads to be focused
on the iphone instead so because of that
the actual mac event was delayed to
november but this year based on all the
leaks and rumors that we have we're not
expecting any delays at all for the
iphone so the event is likely going to
happen on september 14th and that means
that the october event should be going
back to being focused on the mac this
year and on top of that i was digging
into some old leaks and i found this
very interesting one from leaks apple
pro way back in january when he leaked
the timeline for the future mac lineup
first of all he was right about the imac
being the first redesigned apple silicon
mac with different chip options which
ended up being the binned base model
along with the thinner bezels and the
thinner body he just got the march date
wrong because apple delayed the event
into april second of all he claimed that
the macbook air would make its way to a
12-inch flat design which has actually
been rumored very recently and the flat
design aspect matches up to jon
prosser's renders of the macbook air
third he was actually the first one that
claimed that the larger imac would
release in early 2022 with a form factor
that matches the 24-inch imac but being
a bit thicker and with more performance
which i totally agree with and right now
it's been confirmed by dylan dkt that
the imac won't be released until 2022
matching up to leaks apple pros leak and
on top of that he also claimed that the
apple silicon mac pro will be smaller
and released in late 2022 which i also
agree with as well as mark german who
recently reported the same thing and way
back in january he also mentioned that
the mac mini at some point will be
getting an update to allow 10 gigabit
ethernet which apple eventually did on
april 20th so he was correct with that
leak as well leading me to believe that
his source was fully legitimate so this
last piece of info concerning the
macbook pro is likely to be spot on as
well while many others including myself
believed that the m1x macbook pros would
be coming at apple's wwdc event back in
january he claimed that they would
actually be coming in october which now
finally makes perfect sense he also
claimed that the macbook pro would be
getting a flat design language which
matches up to jon prosser's renders of
the macbook air redesign and leaked
schematics of the macbook pro from way
back in april he also mentioned a 14
inch display with multiple chip set
options meaning that the base model of
the macbook pro will likely have a bend
12 core gpu
which i also agree with but the main
detail that he mentioned is october for
the reveal day and on top of all of
those interesting leaks we recently got
a report that the m1x macbook pros have
just entered mass production with apple
expecting to reach as many as 800 000
shipments before the end of november and
for that to happen they would likely
have to get revealed in october and ship
in late october or early november so in
my personal opinion the event will
likely happen on either october 19th or
the 26th since they usually host events
on tuesdays and there is a slight chance
that apple will do an additional event
in november but that just doesn't seem
likely this year and now let's finish
off with the pricing and the best way to
do that is to look at the high-end intel
mac mini that you can still buy right
now on apple's website which starts at
10.99 and comes with 512 gigabytes of
storage which is what we're expecting
for the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros so
that's exactly what we're expecting to
come on the m1x mac mini as well mark
german also expects 16 gigs of ram to be
the minimum amount of ram for the m1x
chip in general which makes sense since
that's the current minimum on the higher
end macbook pros so the m1x mac mini
should come with 16 gigs at the base
price so if you take the current intel
mac mini and configure it with those
specs you're sitting at 12.99 for the
starting price which is the exact price
that i'm expecting for the m1x mac mini
to start at with 16 gigs of ram and 512
gigs of ssd now there is a chance that
apple will give it a 100 discount like
they did with the regular m1 mac mini
compared to the old base lower and intel
model but i believe that that was a
small incentive apple added because the
m1 model lost two thunderbolt ports and
it didn't support as many displays
compared to the old intel base mac mini
so because of that i'm sticking to a
1299 base price prediction for the new
m1x mac mini so with all that said here
is my full specs and features list which
is definitely subject to change as more
leaks and rumors continue to come out
but i'm pretty confident in a lot of
these details now if you disagree with
any of my predictions go ahead and let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed this video
definitely go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]